crispy roast duck with pancakes
with the added kick of a black bean
dipping sauce
megan
you gonna help with the duck dunny your
favorite yes it is now how's your
boyfriend
right i'm going
come on
that woke you up didn't it
so what do you love most about duck the
dipping sauce the dipping sauce i love
that let's get the duck in the oven
first
let's get a bit of salt in there please
then some pepper thank you
some spring onion garlic and ginger now
why didn't we pour that in there
to season it and flavor it
how come you put them in hole like that
and not smaller it's going inside i'm
not using it for sauce or anything so
it's just going to make it really nice
what are they
star anita sorry
so what happens as the duck roasts on
the outside it creates this really nice
perfume aroma inside
tuck that in there
to get it spicy rub
all that chinese five spice yeah over
almost like you're massaging
good
so make sure you get it all in even the
little wings you know underneath her
just like i used to do to you in the
bath
i used to wash your little handys
i know those days are long gone i know i
know i know
long gone
that is seriously spicy with the duck
there's generally quite a lot of fat
there yeah so we're gonna put it on this
little bench
okay
and that
goes
there
by slowly roasting it okay it's gonna
get nice and crisp on the outside all
that fat is gonna render inside the
breast so therefore it's gonna get all
nice and juicy yeah
right ducks in
three and a half hours at 160 degrees
celsius
your favorite part you said was the
dipping sauce why is it your favorite
part
i think it really adds to the dark it
makes it really tasty cena's is your
favorite you can make it i'm gonna do
nothing okay daddy's gonna put his feet
up so
uh first off the garlic
there's one good girl watch your fingers
please always do good
nice
oh you're fast
huh watch your fingers i am
wash your fingers slide slow down
please
14.
all right that's enough
right a little teaspoon of olive oil
in a few years time we'll be teaching
how to drive
as well as cook how exciting is that you
know in a car
scary
okay garlickin
crispy duck is traditionally served with
hoisin sauce but my brood love the
additional big bold punch of black beans
nice
megan and i add soy sauce
and lastly for that classic chinese
sweet and sour element brown rice
vinegar and honey
are you happy with the flavour i'm
really happy
you can taste everything in there
dipping sauce done duck's in the oven
how's the duck doing
crispy
wow
and delicious
how crispy that is it's really crispy
that's what happens when it slow cooks
so 20 minutes for the duck to rest
time to knock up a quick hoisin and
cucumber salad to put in our crispy duck
pancakes
for the dressing combine hoisin sauce
rice wine vinegar
soy sauce
a dash of sesame oil
and to give it that zingy asian punch
some freshly grated root ginger
[Music]
for the salad trim and cut spring onions
into very fine matchsticks
peel a whole cucumber into long thin
ribbons
and shred in a couple of baby gem
lettuces
season and toss this fresh crunchy salad
in the sweet yummy hoisin dressing
a combination that never fails to get
the kids eating their greens done crispy
dipping sauce
cucumber salad ready so if you take them
and your dipping sauce take them over
thank you i'll take the duck
don't drop it promise
oh okay
yeah
it was amazing
my ultimate big and bold dinner of
crispy roast duck with pancakes with a
hoisin dressed salad and some extra
oomph from megan's favorite black bean
dipping sauce
you need the eye
nice
ollie i think you need a bit more duck
in there you heard me home
honestly it's like a black burrito
[Music]